Something akin to passwords have seemingly
been used for at least as long as humans have
been recording history.
For example, one of the earliest references
to something like a password is mentioned
in the Book of Judges, which was first written
down sometime around the 6th or 7th century
BC.
Specifically, it states in Judges 12:
And the Gileadites took the passages of Jordan
before the Ephraimites: and it was so, that
when those Ephraimites which were escaped
said, Let me go over; that the men of Gilead
said unto him, Art thou an Ephraimite?
If he said, Nay;
Then said they unto him, Say now Shibboleth:
and he said Sibboleth: for he could not frame
to pronounce it right.
Then they took him, and slew him at the passages
of Jordan…
Fast-forwarding a bit in history and Roman
legionaries are known to have used a simple
system of passphrases to discern whether a
stranger was friend or foe.
Second century BC Greek historian, Polybius,
even describes in detail how the password
system worked in terms of making sure everyone
knew what the current password was:
…from the tenth maniple of each class of
infantry and cavalry, the maniple which is
encamped at the lower end of the street, a
man is chosen who is relieved from guard duty,
and he attends every day at sunset at the
tent of the tribune, and receiving from him
the watchword—that is a wooden tablet with
the word inscribed on it – takes his leave,
and on returning to his quarters passes on
the watchword and tablet before witnesses
to the commander of the next maniple, who
in turn passes it to the one next him.
All do the same until it reaches the first
maniples, those encamped near the tents of
the tribunes.
These latter are obliged to deliver the tablet
to the tribunes before dark.
So that if all those issued are returned,
the tribune knows that the watchword has been
given to all the maniples, and has passed
through all on its way back to him.
If any one of them is missing, he makes inquiry
at once, as he knows by the marks from what
quarter the tablet has not returned, and whoever
is responsible for the stoppage meets with
the punishment he merits.
Roman historian Suetonius even mentions Caesar
using a simple cipher which required the recipient
to know a key, in this case the correct number
of times to shift the alphabet, to decipher
the message.
As for more modern times, the first known
instance of a password system on an electronic
computer was implemented by now retired professor
of computer science at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology, Fernando Corbato.
In 1961, MIT had a giant time-sharing computer
called the Compatible Time-Sharing System
(CTSS).
Corbato would state in a 2012 interview: “The
key problem [with the CTSS] was that we were
setting up multiple terminals, which were
to be used by multiple persons but with each
person having his own private set of files.
Putting a password on for each individual
user as a lock seemed like a very straightforward
solution.”
Something we should mention before continuing
is that Corbota is hesitant to take credit
for being the first to implement a computer
password system.
He suggests that a device built in 1960 by
IBM called the Semi-Automatic Business Research
Environment (Sabre), which was (and still
is in an upgraded form) used for making and
maintaining travel reservations, probably
used passwords.
However, when IBM was contacted about this,
they were unsure if the system originally
had any such security.
And as nobody seems to have any surviving
record of whether it did, Corbato is seemingly
universally given credit for being the first
to put such a system on an electronic computer.
Of course, an issue with these early proto-passwords
is that all of them were stored in plain text
despite the gaping security hole this introduces.
On that note, in 1962, a PHD student called
Allan Scherr managed to get the CTSS to print
off all of the computer’s passwords.
Scherr notes,
There was a way to request files to be printed
offline, by submitting a punched card with
the account number and file name.
Late one Friday night, I submitted a request
to print the password files and very early
Saturday morning went to the file cabinet
where printouts were placed…
I could then continue my larceny of machine
time.
This “larceny” was simply getting more
than the four hours of allotted daily computer
time he’d been granted.
Scherr then shared the password list to obfuscate
his involvement in the data breech.
System admins at the time simply thought there
must have been a bug in the password system
somewhere and Scherr was never caught.
We only know that he was responsible because
he sheepishly admitted almost a half century
later that it was he who did it.
This little data breach made him the first
known person to steal computer passwords,
something the computer pioneer seems quite
proud of today.
Hilariously, according to Scherr, while some
people used the passwords to get more time
on the machine to run simulations and the
like, others decided to use them to log into
the accounts of people they didn’t like
just to leave insulting messages.
Which just goes to show that while computers
may have changed a lot in the last half century,
people sure haven’t.
In any event, around 5 years later, in 1966,
CTSS once again experience a massive data
breach when a random administrator accidentally
mixed up the files that displayed a welcome
message to each user and the master password
file…
This mistake saw every password stored on
the machine being displayed to any user who
attempted to log into CTSS.
In a paper commemorating the fiftieth anniversary
of CTSS engineer Tom Van Vleck fondly recalled
the “Password Incident” and jokingly noted
of it: “Naturally this happened at 5 PM
on a Friday, and I had to spend several unplanned
hours changing people’s passwords.”
As a way to get around the whole plain text
password problem, Robert Morris created a
one-way encryption system for UNIX which at
least made it so in theory even if someone
could access the password database, they wouldn’t
be able to tell what any of the passwords
were.
Of course, with advancements in computing
power and clever algorithms, even more clever
encryption schemes have had to be developed…
and the battle between white and black hat
security experts has pretty much been waging
back and forth ever since.
This has all led to Bill Gates famously stating
in 2004, “[Passwords] just don’t meet
the challenge for anything you really want
to secure.”
Of course, the biggest security hole is generally
not the algorithms and software used, but
the users themselves.
As famed creator of XKCD, Randall Munroe,
once so poignantly put it, “Through 20 years
of effort, we’ve successfully trained everyone
to use passwords that are hard for humans
to remember, but easy for computers to guess.”
On this note of training people to make bad
passwords, the blame for this can be traced
back to widely disseminated recommendations
by the National Institute of Standards and
Technology, published in the page turner that
was the eight page NIST Special Publication
800-63.
Appendix A, written by Bill Burr in 2003.
Among other things, Burr recommended the use
of words with random characters substituted
in, including requiring capital letters and
numbers, and that system admins have people
change their passwords regularly for maximal
security…
Of these seemingly universally adopted recommendations,
the now retired Burr stated in an interview
with the Wall Street Journal, “Much of what
I did I now regret…”
To be fair to Burr, studies concerning the
human psychology aspect of passwords were
largely non-existent at the time he wrote
these recommendations and in theory certainly
his suggestions at the least should have been
very slightly more secure from a computational
perspective than using regular words.
The problem with these recommendations is
pointed out by the British National Cyber
Security Centre (NCSC) who state, “this
proliferation of password use, and increasingly
complex password requirements, places an unrealistic
demand on most users.
Inevitably, users will devise their own coping
mechanisms to cope with ‘password overload’.
This includes writing down passwords, re-using
the same password across different systems,
or using simple and predictable password creation
strategies.”
To this point, in 2013 Google performed a
quick little study on people’s passwords
and noted that most people use one of the
following in their password scheme: The name
or birthday of a pet, family member or partner;
an anniversary or other significant date;
birthplace; favorite holiday; something to
do with a favorite sports team; and, inexplicable,
the word password…
So, bottom line, most people choose passwords
that are based on information that is easily
accessible to hackers, who then can in turn
relatively easily create a brute force algorithm
to crack the password.
Thankfully, while you might not know it from
the ubiquity of systems out there that still
require you to do your best impression of
Will Hunting to set a password, most security
advisory entities have drastically changed
their recommendations in the last few years.
For example, the aforementioned NCSC now recommends,
among other things, system administrators
stop making people change passwords unless
there is a known password breach within the
system as, “This imposes burdens on the
user (who is likely to choose new passwords
that are only minor variations of the old)
and carries no real benefits…”
Further noting that studies have shown that
“Regular password changing harms rather
than improves security…”
Or as Physicists and noted Computer Scientist
Dr. Alan Woodward of the University of Surrey
notes, “the more often you ask someone to
change their password, the weaker the passwords
they typically choose.”
Similarly, even a completely random set of
characters at typical password requirement
lengths is relatively susceptible to brute
force attacks without further security measures.
As such, the National Institute of Standards
and Technology has likewise updated their
recommendations, now encouraging admins to
have people focus on lengthy, but simple,
passwords.
For example, a password like “My password
is pretty easy to remember.”
is generally going to be orders of magnitude
more secure than “D@ught3rsN@m3!1” or
even “*^sg5!J8H8*@#!^”
Of course, while using such phrases makes
things easy to remember, it still doesn’t
get around the problem of the seemingly weekly
occurrence of some major service having their
database hacked, with said systems sometimes
using weak encryption or even none at all
in their storing of private data and passwords,
such as the recent Equifax hack that saw 145.5
million people in the U.S. have their personal
data exposed, including full names, Social
Security Numbers, birth dates, and addresses.
(Across the pond, Equifax also noted about
15 million UK citizens had their records stolen
in the breach as well.)
In shades of the first ever password hack
mentioned previously which required Scherr
to just request that the password file be
printed, it turns out to get access to the
vast amount of personal data Equifax stores
on people, an anonymous computer security
expert told Motherboard, “All you had to
do was put in a search term and get millions
of results, just instantly—in cleartext,
through a web app.”
Yep…
Because of this sort of thing, the National
Cyber Security Centre also now recommends
admins encourage people to use password manager
software in order to help increase the likelihood
that people use different passwords for different
systems.
In
the age of everyone’s lives being stored
online on various companies’ servers- generally
all protected by passwords, the University
of London noted in a recent study that about
10% of people are now putting a list of their
common passwords in their wills to make sure
people can access their data and accounts
after they die.
Interestingly, the problem of people not doing
this actually is noted as having caused a
major problem after the 9/11 attacks.
For example, Howard Lutnick, a one time executive
at Cantor Fitzgerald, noted his rather unenviable
task of having to track down the passwords
of almost 700 employees who’d died in the
attack.
Because of how critical it was for the company
to have access to their files right away before
the evening bond markets opened, he and his
staff had to call loved ones of the dead to
ask for the passwords or what the passwords
might be that same day…
Thankfully for the company, most of the employees’
passwords were based on the aforementioned
flawed recommendations by Bill Burr- the “J3r3my!”
variety.
This, in combination with specific personal
information from loved ones Lutnick collected,
allowed a team dispatched by Microsoft to
relatively easily crack the unknown passwords
via brute force in short order.